uh this entire threat of an alien
invasion was always in the card starting
in the 50s that they began to hoax
things and position this whole issue
Into The Lunatic Fringe of abductions
and mutilations and were the worlds and
the movie Independence Day and all this
crap the ones that are the UFOs that are
man-made and that's about 70 80 percent
of the ones people see are in fact a
threat to the National Security they're
sort of a covert program that can be
used in a false flag it can be used to
Stage fake abductions and mutilations
and all kinds of scary stuff now to what
end they want to be able to unite the
world around a sort of totalitarian
militaristic group as Ronald Reagan said
wouldn't our job of creating uh unity
and uniting the world be easier if we
had a common alien threat to fight I'm
quoting